[Musique]
c'est une leçon vraiment difficile à apprendre
quand vous êtes jeune et que vous apprenez à laisser
aller quelque chose
euh donc c'est de ça que parle cette chanson
[Musique]
j'avais probablement 21 ans donc
nous venions de signer un contrat d'enregistrement je pense
et je l'ai écrit sur le
clavier électrique de ma mère et quand je l'ai écrit je n'y ai
rien pensé du tout je ne pensais pas que c'était
quelque chose de spécial
j'étais juste une autre chanson c'était assez
facile à écrire
parfois les chansons prennent des années à
produire mais elles  ne prend pas très longtemps à
écrire et je me souviens qu'avec cette chanson je
pense qu'elle est sortie assez
rapidement c'était très très simple comme les
accords réels au piano
même s'il y a du mouvement sont très
très simples c'est une chanson très simple
c'est vraiment  chanson vraiment émouvante, il s'agit
définitivement d'un jeune amour
et de ce sentiment d'être coincé dans un
cycle, je pense que peut-être le
sentiment que vous perdez votre temps
ou votre
énergie et je pense que c'est une leçon très difficile
à apprendre quand vous êtes
quand vous '  Je suis jeune et j'apprends à laisser
faire  quelque chose va
euh donc c'est de quoi parle cette chanson et
je tu sais que j'ai eu cette expérience
plus d'une fois dans ma vie
euh comme la plupart des gens l'ont donc je pense que c'est
pourquoi ça résonne toujours autant
avec les gens et avec moi quand je chante
ça résonne encore
maintenant
[Musique]
on a dit à propos de perdre mes
jeunes années,
surtout ici en France que c'est
une chanson sur une génération
et je pense qu'il y a toujours une dualité
euh dans mes paroles je suis très
motivé par la philosophie et euh
j'ai tendance à  dire des choses à travers euh
ce que signifient mes relations personnelles ou des
choses qui se sont produites mais je dis toujours
autre chose en même temps
et je pense que dans cette chanson,
je pense que parfois au début de la
vingtaine,
vous pouvez en quelque sorte avoir une deuxième
adolescence  ou vous réalisez en fait que vous
savez que vous pensiez que vous étiez vraiment adulte
mais en fait vous êtes si loin d'avoir
grandi à cet âge et
je me souviens avoir eu cet âge et je ne savais tout simplement
pas ce qui se passait
dans la vie et je pense pour  moi  c'est de quoi parlait
cette chanson
je pense qu'il n'y a jamais eu un
moment précis où j'ai vraiment réalisé que
gaspiller mes jeunes années allait bien je
pense que ce qui est vraiment intéressant c'est
qu'avec la
grammaire londonienne il semble que gaspiller mes
jeunes années était un grand
succès en france  mais ce n'était pas tellement au
royaume-uni
au royaume-uni qu'ils aiment le foin maintenant et en
australie ils aiment le foin maintenant et ils
aiment fort
mais certainement en france il y avait
un tel lien avec la perte de mes jeunes années
et
je pense que je n'ai jamais vraiment eu  cette
expérience de réaliser à quel point cette
chanson était liée
quand nous sommes venus faire des concerts ici
et quand nous avons joué cette chanson, c'était tout simplement
incroyable, il y a certainement beaucoup de
larmes,
surtout en France quand nous
jouons
gaspiller mes jeunes années j'ai définitivement
eu  beaucoup de larmes parfois au
premier rang et puis ça me donne envie de
pleurer
je reçois toujours des messages à propos de cette chanson
et c'est juste extraordinaire je trouve
fascinant que tu puisses écrire
quelque chose  cela
pour vous en ce moment semble tellement jeter
euh je n'avais tout simplement aucune idée que cela se
connecterait jamais de la façon dont il l'a fait et cela
signifie que nous avons une carrière tellement incroyable
ici en France et une base de fans incroyable
c'est un peu dur  à la hauteur de je
pense que
je ne pense pas que nous écrirons un jour une
chanson qui se connectera probablement de la
même manière que les moyens de mes jeunes années le font
en france
et mais c'est un cadeau tu sais que
j'ai tellement de chance de
ressentir  comme si j'avais ça et je pense que c'est
tout ce que tu peux espérer en tant qu'artiste